You like India?
I like India
Ah, okay
And bricks are all around
he's chipping away
What a cool find
Before we get going, guys
I want to explain to you
the importance of earplugs in India
in the cycle of noise in this country
So, all day, horns, horns, horns, till 2 a.m.
2 a.m. the horns stop and the dogs start
The dogs go until about 5:00 a.m.
and then the prayer starts, "Allahu Akbar"
Shortly after the horns start again
Earplugs
definitely a must in India
So, today
we're gonna go
on a cool journey
through the streets of Udaipur
which is the city
in the south of Rajasthan
Beautiful lakes, forts, parks, culture
and I'll guarantee one tourist sight for you
the City Palace
But in my style, I like to
capture the feel of the streets
the flavors, the sights, the sounds
and
hopefully meet some locals
because locals always make it more interesting
Okay
Great night of sleep, feels...
feels really good to get
proper rest in a nice place
First impressions last night when I came in
little calmer
little more relaxed
versus Jodhpur where I just came from
which was much more
Still in the same province of Rajasthan
Namaste
in Rajasthan
and Rajasthan is in the western part of the country
It's the biggest state
It has its own culture
it's own traditions, it's own dress
and even within parts of Rajasthan
it's very diverse and different
He's coming through quick
You gotta be on your toes in this country
Yesterday
in the morning
a pigeon dropped some candy wrappers
on my head
At the same time I was stepping in some s**t
and dodging a rickshaw
Good morning
Good morning, sir
That's beautiful
You're painting the door, the color, yeah
It's always a nice feeling to be welcomed
in a country
India is not the only country obviously
but it's one of those countries
where people will go out of their way and say hi
Namaste, good morning
Good morning
What are you doing here?
Silver
Oh, you get the silver out of there?
Aluminum
Oh, the aluminum
You sell the aluminum?
Aluminum
So, you're just pulling it from all these parts?
Get it from all these parts?
I don't know where I'm going to be honest
I'm just walking around
Trying to check out the vibe, the streets
Your brother?
Hi
Hello
So, what I was saying
what I was saying, check it out
This is a small city for India, right?
Yeah
Half million people?
You like India?
I like India
Ah, okay
Beautiful
Okay
We're gonna hold hands?
Yeah, let's go
High five?
Low five
Ah, what you got in there?
Whatever he has in his hands
he got me with it
Cool old door
A lot of cool old doors here
A lot of stories in these doors
You did that
You make the shoes here?
Oh, you have a mold
Great, so there's a mold
and you just put the leather around and...
So, it's a very positive...
Powerful energy
Powerful energy and positive sign?
Yeah
You see these swastikas all over the place and
well, Hitler took it and killed it
The meaning at least
What these guys are doing...
These guys are moving some coal
That's a tough job, damn
That's serious
Wow
Thank you
So, I was just scoping out this coal operation
and...
Thank you
And they decided to stop and get me some tea
This is for you
Present
Thank you, sir
Thank you for the tea
I don't have one for you, no
I gave them chocolate
Chocolate
Not for you
These guys are doing the hard work
Beautiful horse
Looks good
Every culture is different with the camera
Hello
And...
some are easier and some are harder to shoot
I was just in Saudi Arabia
that was super hard to to shoot stuff like that
And then here it's
they just don't care
like you can put the camera anywhere
Peter
What is your name?
Sakina
Ayush
Aldis
The Cool Guy
What's your shirt say?
I love my India
I love your India too
He's matching quite well
Namaste
Cool flow to this building
Streamline modern style
Falling apart but you can see
the shape and the form is there
Food has been awesome in Rajasthan
I'll show you guys in a little bit
when I get lunch or dinner
what I'm talking about
Hello, sir. No, I don't need a tuk-tuk
No problem, thank you
I'm looking for a motorcycle
Maybe this guy
What's your name?
Halib
Halib, Peter
And you take a scan?
India is the type of place where
if you ask for it
a lot of times you'll get it
For example, the bike
just some random guy
"Hey, man, can I get on"
"the back of your motor with you?"
And let's cruise
and he's just, "Sure, why not?"
If you're going to travel here, like
definitely
get off the grid a little bit
get out of the tourist areas
and let it flow
get a little bit lost
go around that next corner
because then all these things open up
So, that's India for you
Just go down the rabbit hole
I like this
This is very good
So, this is like
sort of a fried dough in a syrup
It's like something you get at a carnival
It's different but it's similar
Little argument here
I think there'd be a lot of that because
there's a lot of jockeying for space in this country
Like space is a premium
Wow!
Please, see that
You're not getting my iPhone
He's the boss man?
Subash
Subash, okay
Got a great audience here
Hey, guys
Hi
Oh, that's a God?
Yeah
That was good
I must go
Bye-bye
Okay, guys, we're making it out to what
Udaipur is famous for
the lakes, the temples
the monuments
Here we go
Wow!
Beautiful
Just a boat
Lake
Some islands out here
Some ladies washing
Wow
And mountain
I don't know if you can see it through the haze
but there's a mountain back there
This structure was completely covered by these bricks
Because
the cement and bricks are all around
he's chipping it away
Wow!
What a cool find
You can see it's just...
It was covered
Oh, wow!
No way!
That is amazing
That's beautiful
Yeah, you finished that
Just clean, perfect, huh?
All the areas chipped away
You like bikes?
I like bikes, yeah
Like bikes, sir?
Yeah, I like bikes
Country bikes, do you like country bikes?
I like bikes, yeah
That's gonna take some fact checking
but that's what it looks like at least like
like they're chipping away the bricks and cement
Here we have
some painting going on
They're really sprucing this place up
On the other side of the lake here, guys
Looking back
at
this beauty
and we're gonna get in there
in a little bit
Namaste
City Palace, yeah?
Oh, this looks like the cool place for young guys
to hang out
listen to the music
Welcome, sir
Okay, thank you
And it was never taken over?
So, this is close to everyone's heart?
He won against Akbar, right?
Well, that's it
That's all
That was Udaipur
Very cool city
Absolutely exhausted
and just because of all the interaction and stimulation
Lot of love here, not one bad experience
and I always like the street life more
than, say, temples and monuments
and there's so much to get on these streets here
And everything else is super beautiful
wonderful place, loved it
If you wanna see more of my India series
I have a playlist
Many more videos on India so
Thanks for coming along
That was fun
Okay, until next one